oh hello may I speak to George P Smith
yes yes he hello my name is Adam Smith
I'm calling from nobelprize.org the
official website of the Nobel Prize in
Stockholm
well many congratulations on the award
of the prize thank you very much
it's what coming up to 5:00 a.m. there
did it what did the call wake you no
actually had just woken up
you know elderly people have a difficult
time sleeping sometimes so I got up
really early at about 4:00 what was your
first reaction on hearing the news great
surprise actually I thought it was one
of these sort of numerous jokes Jim call
coming in from Stockholm which is kind
of like a I mean that's really what I
kind of thought it was but there was so
much static online I knew it had to be
real it's going we going back to 1985
when you had this idea to get viruses
that infect bacteria to display peptides
for you did the idea come to you
suddenly or was it a long process
certainly not certainly no it was an
idea from with many sources because I
had all these streams that was very much
in my background at the time so so he
was definitely not something that just
popped into my head but so much a case
of being the right person in the right
place at the right time it is very much
the right person the right time I mean I
was trained in immunology but I also
knew a lot about this stage of the stage
and and and in in classical you know
molecular biology that's what my basic
training wasn't in college you never
know which pieces of information are
going to be useful on what you're going
to need to combine to make something
happen I suppose well I think that's
very very true it's like evolution you'd
really don't know which mutation is
going to be though the one that you know
that flourishes
were you surprised by the rapidity with
which it was all taken up and you know
it was as I say all those precedents
that were in the air so no I wasn't that
surprised actually and I certainly
wasn't surprised I mean another I'm
sharing that might have are half with
Greg winter so he came out of this
Cambridge group that had been as they
were calling a cloning cloning the
immune system at the time so that was
that was very similar very allied line
of reasoning line line of research and I
was very aware of that too
so I actually wasn't surprised that it
that people would catch on to it because
it was something that was it was a way
of thinking is very much in the air at
the time but did you dream that it would
lead to for instance the therapeutic
antibodies that came out of winters work
well that's a good question I don't I
don't think that I thought certainly in
85 that I would have that I thought in
those terms although I was very much
interested in anybody's and very much
aware of the work and Cambridge group
but when the first publication of single
chain antibodies single chain anybody's
are sort of carried down anybody says
have the central feature of binding to
specifically to an antigen but are
missing a whole bunch of other things
and our single polypeptide chains at
that point it became quite obvious that
well I won't say quite obviously but
it's it seemed very plausible but not
just small peptides but my larger folded
domains like single chain anybody's
could be displayed on on phase just like
small peptides and of course the
Cambridge group realized that at the
same time so shallow and
I'm sorry your journey to be part oh
well I guess it seems so at the time you
know so many years later it's seems a
little bit old half but what and I know
you haven't that long for it to sink in
but what do you think the price means do
you do you mean what does it mean
personally yeah I don't know that's a
really good question I have no idea I
was completely unprepared for this my
life I mean I've been retired for three
years and I have very different
interests now and so that really that
that remains a question to be answered I
don't know what this this will mean for
my life well you have plenty of time to
find out and plenty of time to mull over
it before you come to Stockholm December
apparently have you know like a few
minutes before reporters are going to be
ringing the phone off the hook I'm
afraid I think the date is going to take
a very different turn so it's been a
huge pleasure speaking to you once again
many many congratulations okay